allora lievito sicuramente voglio fare
un salto di pete se poi devo comprare fa
tante mascherine perché bisogna
cambiarla dopo ogni utilizzo
ok io aspetto ormai non si sa mai non si
sa mai
la mascherina mi sono dimenticata la
mascherina non mi fanno entrare
supermercato senza ciò voglio e torna
alla casa prende ecco dove era finita la
mia mascherina è volata via
amy è mia
grazie anna che ma che vuoi ma che buon
profumo questo c'è ma è proprio
idratante sento proprio finita la pelle
ma per cosa dell'aloe vera ma mi dice la
barca perché o meglio comprare anch'io
eccezionale
wow grazie oddio ma non mi si staccano
le mani ma che e colla quella non è già
l
che cos'è questo bene a te ma mi sei
stadi per roma
nonostante tutto almeno a qualcosa è
servito stare chiusa in casa tutti
questi mesi sono tornata a prendermi
cura del mio corpo allenandomi tutti i
giorni glutei cosce addominali braccia
sono davvero orgogliosa di me stessa
ok oggi e lunedì e quindi dovrei
iniziare ad allenarmi dovrei ma non
posso perché un ciclo non è che ci si
può allenare quando sia riciclo dai oggi
oggi mi devo allenare cioè non è che
posso continuare a trovare scuse però
ieri sera ho iniziato una serie
bellissima c'è non è che riesco ad
aspettare ancora domani la devo finire
poi è ora di merenda quindi tra una cosa
e l'altra facciamo domani
sono così contenta di vedere che
nonostante tutto continuo a studiare ea
seguire attentamente le tue video
lezioni sono proprio orgoglio
leggiamo i due che la bambina sta
studiando grazie mamma allora maria la
ricetta facile facile prendi 300 g di
farina fai un bel buco e mezzo esclama
ma sto studiando con impasti fai un bel
panetto compatto lo butti in frigo con
un bel mattina in su per far silenzio in
casa mia è va in camera o in bagno e se
devi studiare che qui c'è gente che
lavora ma no e marina con la sua classe
online se volevo anche due etti di
mortadella per favore
scusi scusi si può allontanare scusi non
stiamo rispettando il metro di distanza
scusi eh no un po di più io tengo la mia
salute se permette sia allora volevo due
etti di mortadella grazia signora se
posso riprende anche il culo e
buonissima silfidi allora anche il
signore gli ha consigliato duetti di
cresciuto grazie gentilissima scusi
posso reggo frego
ma che cosa è la nuova colonia che
vengano più dietro l'angolo
va bene ma la voglio comprare mai fatto
una buonissima amore mio
vorrei tanto sfiorare le tue labbra in
un bacio lungo e appassionato che non
finisce più
ma purtroppo per ora non possiamo e mi
devo accontentare di un asettico e moggi
che però inviata da te e le voci più
belle ed emozionanti di sempre
ma sì ma tanto siamo quasi congiunti non
ci scoprirà nessuno adesso vieni e fammi
tu